- The headline is Roe vs. Wade
is dead, but is that true?
Well, that is mostly the case,
but the reality of this
particular situation
is so much worse than that
headline makes it seem.
And I'm not talking about that
from a political standpoint
of the idea that the
constitutional enshrinement of
a woman's right to choose
may be dead in America,
but rather the procedural machinations
of what happened in this
particular case are bad
for the rule of law.
It creates uncertainty and
it hurts the legitimacy
of the Supreme Court,
regardless of where you fall
on the political spectrum.
The outcome in this case
is not good for anyone
because in the dead of night,
without any judge signing the decision.
five conservative Justices on
the Supreme court overruled
the right to abortion.
Allowing a Texas law banning
all abortions after six weeks
to go into effect with no
exceptions for rape or incest.
And to accomplish this,
the five Justice majority acquiesce to
a procedural trick dreamed up by
the Texas legislature
explicitly for the purpose
of evading federal judicial review.
This isn't the way that
any cases are supposed
to be decided.
Let alone one of the most
important cases that has ever come
before the Supreme court.
(dramatic music)
Hey, legal eagles.
It's time to think like a
constitutional scholar because
in 1973, Roe vs Wade
challenged a Texas law,
that criminalized helping
a woman get an abortion.
The Supreme court ruled that
the law was unconstitutional,
that women had a right
to an abortion during
their first trimester.
48 years later in 2021,
Texas passed a new bill
that outlawed abortion
after six weeks,
a clear violation of Roe
and the subsequent Casey
vs Planned Parenthood case.
Rather than criminalizing abortion,
this time Texas gave private
citizens the right to sue
anyone who aids a person
in getting an abortion,
giving them a chance to win $10,000.
If they were willing
to narc on the abetter.
The law also created a
procedural Rube Goldberg machine
meant to deny anyone
the right to challenge
that law in federal court.
So what did the Supreme
court do on Wednesday night?
Did they overrule Roe
vs. Wade and it's progeny
without doing so explicitly?
And what happens to all
of the women who are stuck
in the middle in Texas?
Well, it's time to find out.
So let's talk about a summary
of how the Supreme court got
to what is still technically
the law of the land today
and how the Supreme court
found a right of privacy,
which then led to a
woman's right to choose.
Now, as we've covered on
this channel in the past,
the right to privacy is
not specifically mentioned
in the US constitution,
but according to still
technically current jurisprudence
from the Supreme Court,
they have found that that right to privacy
is implied by several amendments.
The first amendment
allows a person to choose
any religious belief and to
keep their choice private.
The fourth amendment protects
against unreasonable
violations of privacy,
government searches and seizures.
The third amendment
establishes his own a privacy
in a person's home.
The fifth amend creates a right
against self-incrimination,
which therefore protects
someone's private information.
The ninth amendment says
that the enumeration of
the constitution of a certain rights
shall not be construed to deny
or disparage other rights
retained by the people.
Courts have interpreted this as allowing
for broad protections of
privacy rights in ways
not specifically listed in
the first eight amendments.
And the 14th amendment prohibits
states from making laws
that infringe upon a person's autonomy,
protections provided for
in the first 13 amendments.
Without this right to privacy,
states would be allowed to
prohibit married couples
from using contraception.
It would criminalize certain kinds
of intimate sexual contact
between consenting adults.
It would ban teenagers
from using birth control
and it would outlaw
abortion because before
the Supreme court's decision
in Griswold versus Connecticut,
it was legal for states to
ban all of that behavior.
Now, abortion rights in the
US are controlled generally
by two cases, Roe vs. Wade
and Planned Parenthood vs. Casey.
This is a very, very brief summary,
but Roe struck down a Texas
law that criminalized aiding
a woman in getting an abortion.
The Supreme Court ruled
that this was a violation
of the due process clause,
the 14th amendment,
because it violated a woman's
fundamental right to privacy.
First trimester abortion
became legal for any reason
and abortions in the second
and third trimesters were restricted
unless certain conditions, like risk
to the mother's life, were met.
Now in 1992 in Planned
Parenthood vs. Casey,
the court more or less
reaffirmed the holding of Roe
that women had a right to
a safe and legal abortion,
but altered the standard for analyzing
the restrictions to that right.
The court overturned the
trimester framework entirely
in favor of a viability analysis.
The court's decision also replaced
these strict scrutiny
standard of review required
by Roe with the undue burden standard,
under which abortion restrictions
were unconstitutional
when they were enacted, quote,
"For the purpose or effect
of placing a substantial
obstacle in the path of
a woman seeking an abortion
of a non-viable fetus."
Crucially before
viability, Casey says that
the state's interests are
not sufficient to interfere
with a woman's right to choose.
Which takes us to this
current Texas heartbeat bill.
Here at issue is Texas Senate bill eight,
which effectively makes
abortion illegal after six weeks
with no exceptions for anything
including rape or incest.
And it doesn't even take
viability into account.
This plainly contravenes the
holdings of Roe and Casey,
the legislature admits
that this is exactly
what they intended to do,
asserting that there is no
obligation to follow federal law.
Quote, "The legislature
finds that the state
of Texas never repealed either
expressly or by implication,
the state statutes
enacted before the ruling
in Roe vs. Wade that prohibit
and criminalize abortion
unless the mother's life is in danger."
Under SB8, any Texas
resident can sue a person for
abetting an abortion and collect a minimum
of $10,000 plus attorney's fees.
Section 171.208 B list the
remedies permitted by this new
cause of action for these
private attorneys general,
if a claimant prevails in
an action brought under
the section, the court shall
award injunctive relief,
sufficient to prevent the
defendant from violating
this sub chapter or
engaging in acts that aid
or abet violations of the sub chapter.
Two, statutory damages in an
amount not less than $10,000
for each abortion that
the defendant performed
or induced in violation of the sub chapter
and for each abortion performed or induced
in violation of the sub chapter,
the defendant aided and abetted.
And three, costs and attorney's fees.
And the last, one costs
and attorney's fees,
is one way, only successful
plaintiffs are entitled
to costs and attorney's fees.
Successful defendants are not,
it is a one-way fee shifting provision.
Now this law was written
very strategically.
It doesn't allow private bounty
hunters to sue the women,
but it's written very broadly
so that anyone who helps
a pregnant person could be sued.
Anyone who pays for or
reimburses cost of an abortion
through insurance or otherwise
can be in an abetter.
This means a person's friends,
family, doctor, counselor,
minister, could be sued.
This could be an Uber driver or a person
who contributes funds for an abortion.
This is also of course,
an attack on employees
of abortion clinics.
Since anyone who works there is liable
if they defy this law and help
induce an abortion to occur.
In the event, a person successfully
sues abortion provider,
the court must permanently shut it down.
And if the defendant in one of these cases
actually prevails, they're not permitted
to seek attorney's fees
from the other side,
only the plaintiffs are.
As Justice Sotomayer
explained in her dissent,
the law quote, deputizes
the state's citizens
as bounty hunters,
offering them cash prizes
for civilly prosecuting their
neighbor's medical procedures.
So there are obviously
plenty of things about SB8
that we would ordinarily expect
to be struck down in court
after a full hearing on
the merits of the law.
It's clearly in violation of
Planned Parenthood vs. Casey.
But that's not what the
Supreme court did here.
Instead, they took advantage
of a Kafka-esque procedure
created by the Texas legislature.
The Supreme Court's 1908
decision in ex parte young,
established that someone raising
a constitutional challenge
to a state law can sue
the state officer charged
with enforcing that law.
So usually when a state
passes an anti-abortion law,
abortion providers file a
pre enforcement suit against
the state officials in federal court,
challenging its constitutionality.
They are allowed to file this suit because
if an unconstitutional
law goes into effect,
it will immediately
curtail individual rights.
And when a district court
grants a preliminary injunction,
the law never actually goes into effect.
This has happened
repeatedly over the decades,
frustrating conservative
attempts to overturn Roe.
So how did the Texas law get
around federal court deference to Roe?
Well, it eliminated the
state officials from
the equation so that there aren't
any state officials who can be sued.
The law states, quote,
"The requirement of the
subchapter shall be enforced
exclusively through
private civil actions."
The law can be enforced by
anyone who is against abortion,
but it can't be enforced by
state or local officials.
Meanwhile, abortion clinics,
can't sue the state of Texas
because no state official has
the power to enforce this law.
And if a court entered
an injunction against
the enforcement of the law,
the argument is that it would be null
because state officials have nothing
to do with enforcing this law.
The Texas attorney general, and
other state officials, can't
enforce this law, so
theoretically they can't be sued.
Other common targets can't be sued either.
The governor has no
power to enforce the law.
So he can't be sued.
You can't sue the Texas legislature
because they have legislative immunity.
So the only litigants who
can challenge SB8 are people
and organizations who are
actually sued in civil court.
But it's not clear whether a
person who is sued can actually
say that the law is unconstitutional.
That's because section 171.208 E,
eliminates several defenses,
one, ignorance or mistake of the law,
two, defendant's belief
that the requirements
of the sub chapter are unconstitutional
or were unconstitutional,
three, a defense reliance
on any court decision
that has been overruled on
appeal or by subsequent court.
Even if that court decision
had not been overruled
when the defendant engaged in conduct
that violates the sub chapter,
four, defendant's reliance on any state
or federal court decision
that's not binding on
this court in which the
action has been brought,
five, non-mutual issue preclusion
or non-mutual claim preclusion,
six, the consent of the
unborn child's mother to
the abortion and seven,
any claim that the
enforcement of the sub chapter
or the imposition of
civil liability against
the defendant will violate
the constitutional rights
of third parties, except
as provided by 171.209
and section 171.209 expressly
denies third party standing
in state court.
Texas has argued that since a
pregnant women can't be sued,
a pregnant person lacks
standing to challenge the law.
And under this law, pregnant women
are deprived of any agency.
And a third party like
an insurance company
or abortion rights
group also cannot invoke
the constitutional rights of a third party
unless the Supreme Court
gives them standing.
And note that this law is
specifically taking aim
at the current exstance
jurisprudence on the Supreme court
and says that if Roe or
Casey is overturned by
the Supreme court, you
weren't allowed to rely on
the Supreme court jurisprudence
because it was later overturned.
So there's absolutely no doubt
whatsoever that this law was
written specifically with an intent
towards avoiding federal oversight.
It's sort of evil genius in that respect.
And normally that wouldn't
necessarily be an issue,
but the Supreme court, as we'll
talk about in just a minute,
has acquiesced to the gamesmanship
of this particular bill
in a way that I don't think
I've ever seen before,
but let's talk about the
procedural history of what happened
when this law was passed,
because that raises questions too.
Texas Governor Greg Abbott signed
the Texas law on May 19th, 2021.
The law is known as a heartbeat bill,
which bans doctors from
performing abortions
once they can detect a
fetal heartbeat around
the sixth week of pregnancy.
Over 15 states have
enacted heartbeat bills
and federal courts have
struck down each one
because they violate the right
to an abortion established
by Roe and Casey.
And despite their unconstitutionality,
legislatures keep passing the bills.
Texas added these unique
provisions to the new law,
which allow private citizens
to collect civil bounties
for snitching on anyone
that abets an abortion.
As it aside, there are
many laws like these on
the books, they're called
private attorney general laws,
where someone who isn't
personally affected by
the law can sue on someone else's behalf.
If there is indeed a violation of the law.
Generally it has been
democratic legislatures
that have passed private
attorneys generals law,
because they allow individuals to enforce
the law against generally
large corporations.
And you often see this
in a class context where
there are small violations
that you aggregate
on behalf of a class of people.
And often it was generally
the conservative executives
that railed against these particular laws.
These were the kinds of things
that president Reagan railed
against saying that really the
only people that made money
were the trial lawyers
and that we needed things
like tort reform.
So if nothing else that
is perhaps ironic that
the Texas legislature has
adopted this particular tool.
Now in July 2021,
Texas abortion providers
sued to enjoin the law before
it became effective on September 1st.
Since the providers
can't sue state officials
and the legislature
has immunity from suit,
the provider sued the court
personnel who are responsible
for enforcing the law.
A state judge, and a county court clerk.
They also sued Mark Dixon,
an anti-abortion activists
who, plaintiff's assume, would
be one of the first people
to file lawsuits to collect the bounties.
Now that's generally a no-no
because courts are not in
the business of offering
perspective opinions.
And the court clerk,
judge and activist filed
a motion to dismiss,
but the federal district
court Judge Pittman,
presided and denied the
motion on August 25th,
allowing the suit to go forward.
The federal court agreed
with plaintiffs that
the defense would in fact,
play a role in enforcing the statutes,
either by filing a lawsuit
or by adjudicating them,
the defendants quickly filed
an appeal on the motion
to dismiss with the fifth circuit,
the court of appeals
that hears the appeals
from the district court.
The defendants also
wanted the appeals court
to halt other proceedings
in the district court,
including a hearing on
the challengers request
for preliminary injunction
that was scheduled
for August 30th.
Now, up until this point,
this was a fairly standard
trip to the court of appeals
in a pre enforcement action.
However, this is where
the normal process ended.
The fifth circuit granted
the defendant's requests,
it canceled the upcoming
hearing and granted the motion
to stop the district court proceedings
and then denied the plaintiff's request
to expedite the appeal.
So in other words,
the fifth circuit stopped
the district court
from stopping the law
from going into effect.
And the fifth circuit declined to explain
the basis for its ruling.
So the plaintiffs had
to appeal directly to
the Supreme Court for
an injunction in joining
the law from going into effect while
the legal case wound its way through
the courts for a marriage decision.
Remember this point, no marriage
decision has been decided.
A full decision SB8
would normally take years
to resolve by the district court,
the court of appeals of the fifth circuit
and then the Supreme Court.
So with this request in
front of the Supreme Court,
under this procedure, the
emergency motion first went
to Justice Alito who was assigned
to hear emergency requests
from Texas.
Well, Alito had the
right to act on his own
or refer to the full court.
And he chose to refer it
to the full Supreme Court.
There, one day after the
law went into effect,
a five Justice majority
ruled that there was no harm
that justified in emergency stay.
The unsigned order from
the Supreme Court stated
that it was uncertain
whether the court clerk
and judge would be asked to
enforce the new abortion law.
Basically they were saying
that they had no idea
whether anti-abortion activists
who had waited over 40 years
for this moment would not necessarily seek
to enforce the law immediately.
This, by the way, is part of the courts,
probably unfairly named shadow docket.
In other words,
this isn't a full appeal
to the Supreme court.
It's an emergency application
that often these things
are decided just by not taking them up.
It's actually fairly rare
to get a decision from
the majority when they
say that they're not going
to grant a injunctive relief.
And what they do in this
particular case is they basically
say that while the law is
probably unconstitutional,
there are some procedural
quirks that are not going
to allow them to get to
these questions right now.
And they just don't see the need
to grant injunctive emergency relief.
And here is the entirety of
the Supreme court's decision.
It's about 500 words from this
unsigned five conservative
Justice majority.
Quote, "The application
for injunctive relief or in
the alternative, to vacate the stays of
the district court proceedings
presented to Justice Alito,
and by him referred to
the court is denied.
To prevail in an application
for a stay or an injunction,
an applicant must carry
the burden of making
a strong showing that it is
likely to succeed on the merits
and that it will be irreparably injured,
absent a stay, that the balance
of the equities favors it
and that a stay is consistent
with a public interest."
So far, so good.
That's completely normal.
That is the standard for a
temporary restraining order in
an emergency context like this.
"The applicants now before is
have raised serious questions
regarding constitutionality
on the Texas law at issue."
Yeah, no kidding.
"But their application
also presents complex
and novel antecedent procedural questions
on which they have not
carried their burden.
For example, federal
courts enjoy the power
to enjoin individuals
tasked with enforcing laws,
not the laws themselves.
And it is unclear whether
the named defendants
in this lawsuit can or
will seek to enforce
the Texas law against the
applicants in a manner
that might permit our intervention.
The state has represented
that neither it nor
its executive employees
possess the authority
to enforce the Texas law
either directly or indirectly,
nor is it clear whether
under existing precedent,
the court can issue an
injunction against state judges
asked to decide a lawsuit under Texas law.
Finally, the sole private
citizen respondent
before us has filed an affidavit stating
that he has no present
intention to enforce the law.
In light of such issues, we cannot say
that applicants have met
their burden to prevail
in an injunction or stay application.
In reaching this conclusion,
we stress that we do not
purport to resolve definitively
any jurisdictional or substantive claim in
the applicant's lawsuit.
In particular, this order is not based on
any conclusion about the
constitutionality of Texas's law
and in no way limits other
procedurally proper challenges
to Texas's law, including
in Texas state courts."
This decision raises so many questions.
First can plaintiffs
actually sue the court clerk
and judge in this kind of situation?
Justice Briar's descent suggested
the answer would certainly be yes,
since you can't have a right
without a remedy to enforce it.
Quote, "It should prove possible
to apply procedures
adequate to that task here,
perhaps by permitting lawsuits against
a subset of delegatetees,
say those particularly likely to exercise
the delegated powers or
perhaps by permitting lawsuits
against officials whose
actions are necessary
to implement the statute's
enforcement powers."
And that's also the gist of district court
Judge Pittman's order on August 25th,
quote, "While empowering
private enforcers SB8 limits
the defenses available to defendants
and subjects them to a
fee shifting regime skewed
in favor of claimants.
For example, defendants
in SB8 enforcement actions
are prohibited from raising
certain defenses enumerated
under SB8, including they believed the law
was unconstitutional that they relied on
a court decision, later overruled,
that was in place at the
time of the acts underlying
the suit or that the patient
consented to the abortion.
Section five of SB8 requires
state judges to weigh
the undue burden anew
in every case as part
of an affirmative defense inline
with SB8's new strictures
regarding construction
and separability of claims."
Judge Pittman noted that SB8
doesn't leave state officials
with nothing to do, instead the law as it
has now codified, empower state agencies
to bring administrative and
civil enforcement actions
against medical
professionals who participate
in abortions that violate
the six week ban based
on their state issued licenses.
And under the state medical
practice act for examples,
the state medical board
must initiate investigations
and disciplinary action against,
as well as refuse to
issue or renew licenses
to licensed physicians who
violate the provision of SB8.
The state nursing and pharmacy
boards and health and human
services divisions also perform
similar administrative functions.
Judge Pittman's point was that
if providers were not able
to perform abortions,
they faced private enforcement actions,
as well as professional
disciplinary sanctions,
which are enforced by the state.
And although parenthetically
that when you involve
the judicial system in enforcing things
in other contexts that
clearly involves state action.
For example, the limits of
defamation law fall under
the first amendment,
because it's the court that is enforcing
defamation judgements and same with
the courts inherent contempt authority.
Often that runs right up against
the first amendment because
it's the judge who is
doing something in court,
that is a state action.
In this case,
both the fifth circuit and
the Supreme court bent over
backwards to make sure that
this law would go into effect,
which is probably going to
cause chaos within Texas,
because people just don't
know what's going to happen.
And what the status of the law is.
And we know that this is beyond the pale
because chief Justice
Roberts wrote in his dissent
that if nothing else,
that the court should have
enjoined the law from going
into effect so that
there was proper time for
the case to wind its way
through the fifth circuit
and Supreme Court on
actual merits decisions.
That was not completely
unusual for the Supreme Court
to grant an emergency stay,
which prevents the laws
enforcement until the case makes
its way through the courts
and for a party to prevail,
they have to show that there
would be irreparable harm
and that they would be likely
to prevail on the merits.
In a case like this,
there would presumably
be irreparable harm,
people who wanted abortions,
but were unable to get them.
In a party making that argument
would be extremely likely
to succeed on the merits
since a six week ban
on abortion goes directly
against Roe and Casey.
But the Supreme court's
majority claimed that
these providers failed
to make a strong showing
that their legal arguments
would be likely to succeed on
the marriage, which is
basically telegraphing that
the Supreme Court will,
when given the chance,
overrule Roe vs Wade
right out in the open,
when they have the opportunity.
But here in this particular case,
they're splitting the baby because
the majority specifically states that
the law raises real
constitutional questions,
but punts because of the crazy
cockamamie procedure that
the Texas legislature created.
This is completely nuts.
One would think that if
you recognize the clear
unconstitutionality based on
the court's current jurisprudence,
Casey is still technically good law.
Then it would only doubly
mean that you should enjoin
this law if they have this crazy
Rube Goldberg machine built
into this law,
not letting them get a free
pass because of the machinations
that they've created here.
And in her dissent Justice Sonia Sotomayor
did not mince words about this move.
Quote, "The court has
rewarded the state's efforts
to delay federal court review of
a plainly unconstitutional statute,
enacted in disregard of
the court's precedents
through procedural entanglements of
the state's own creation.
The court should not
be so content to ignore
its constitutional obligations to protect,
not only the rights of women,
but also the sanctity of its precedents
and the rule of law."
Chief Justice Roberts also
dissented the same lines, quote,
"The statutory scheme before
the court is not only unusual,
but unprecedented.
The legislature has imposed
a prohibition on abortions
after roughly six weeks and
then essentially delegated
enforcement of that prohibition
to the populace at large,
the desired consequences appears to be,
to insulate the state from
responsibility for implementing
and enforcing the regulatory regime."
Justice Briar disagreed
with the majority's view
that his hands were
procedurally tied, quote,
"Texas law delegates
to private individuals,
the power to prevent a woman
from obtaining an abortion
during the first stage of pregnancy.
But a woman has a federal
constitutional right
to obtain abortion
during that first stage."
And Justice Kagan's dissent
called out her colleagues
for abusing the shadow docket.
Quote, "Yet the majority has
acted without any guidance
from the court of appeals,
which is right now
considering the same issues.
It has reviewed only the most
cursory party submissions,
and then only hastily.
And it barely bothers to
explain this conclusion that
the challenge to an obviously
unconstitutional abortion
regulation backed by
a wholly unprecedented enforcement scheme
is unlikely to prevail.
In all these ways, the
majority's decision is emblematic
of too much of this court's
shadow docket decision-making,
which every day becomes more unreasoned,
inconsistent and impossible to defend."
So regardless of where you
stand on the political issue
of abortion,
this is just bad lawmaking
and bad decision-making,
it's bad for the rule of law.
The way that the court went about this,
allowing the fifth circuit to undo
the preliminary injunction
that the district court put
in place has created massive
uncertainty for no reason.
The Supreme court will probably overrule
Roe vs. Wade in the next term.
Why go about this half-hearted
measure to do it on
the shadow docket ahead of time?
It also leaves open all
kinds of new, crazy laws.
It telegraphs to every
state in the country that
they can get around constitutional issues
and constitutional review by simply using
the same private bounty
hunter enforcement mechanism.
And it could go both ways.
Imagine if a state passed a law that said,
if you aid or abet someone
exercising their freedom
of religion, then you're
subject to a $10,000 fine,
and you have to pay the
other side's attorney's fees.
Or on the other side of
the political spectrum,
if you aid or abet
someone buying a firearm
and exercising their
second amendment rights,
then you are subject to
tens of thousands of dollars
in fines, and you have to pay
the other side's attorney's fees
because only private individuals are going
to enforce this anti handgun measure.
But in reality, none of
that's going to happen
because this was an ad hoc decision
with one outcome in mind.
If a similar law comes up
in a different context,
the Supreme court will
just simply say that
it's different for some ad hoc reason,
and it will enjoin those
laws from going into effect.
Again, this isn't necessarily about
the political issue of abortion.
It's about trying to uphold
consistency with the law
and the rule of law itself.
This is terrible for all kinds
of jurisprudential reasons.
Though, as an aside, remember
that this is only with respect
to whether the right to
an abortion or the right
to choose is enshrined within
the constitution itself.
There are always
legislative remedies here.
Congress could pass a
law that grants exactly
the same rights as
conferred by Roe vs. Wade
or Planned Parenthood vs Casey.
Of course a law can always be undone,
but of course it's
harder to undo a law once
it's been passed.
And obviously there are
procedural issues with
the filibuster that make it unlikely that
the bare democratic majority in the House
and the Senate would be
able to pass such a law,
but that is always an option here.
Now, the headline Roe vs. Wade is dead,
might be a slight exaggeration
because technically
Planned Parenthood vs Casey
is still the law of the land.
But the law in Texas has been changed.
And Roe vs. Wade, if not
dead, is on life support.
And it looks like it's
only a matter of time until
the current makeup of the
Supreme court finishes
the job that they started on Wednesday.
Though, the Justice
department has now filed
a lawsuit against the state of Texas,
but it probably won't succeed
in any meaningful way.
In the complaint, the DOJ
argues that the states
have no right to quote impede burden or
in any manner controlled the operations of
the constitutional laws
enacted by Congress
to carry into effect the powers vested
in the national government.
A state law is invalid, if it, quote,
"Stands as an obstacle
to the accomplishment
and execution of the full
purposes and objectives
of Congress, or if it
directly regulates quote,
the activities of the federal government."
The US has also sued to
assert other federal interests
that they claim SB8
unconstitutionally impairs.
The statute is alleged to
have unconstitutionally
restricted the labor
department's job core program,
the defense departments
Tri-Care health program,
the office of refugee settlement,
the bureau of prisons,
the centers of Medicare
and Medicaid services
and the office of personnel management.
And that's not surprising
because as we talked about,
SB8 bans nearly all abortions in the state
after six weeks of pregnancy,
which is in direct conflict
with Planned Parenthood vs Casey.
But the problem here is that
Planned Parenthood vs Casey
probably won't be the law next term,
when the Supreme court takes up one
of several abortion related cases.
And as we talked about
cases that are decided on
the shadow docket related
to emergency petitions,
don't carry any precedential value,
but it does telegraph
what the various Justices
are willing to do and in what context.
And this is a pretty clear
signal that they're going
to overrule Planned Parenthood
vs Casey and Roe vs. Wade
when it comes up on the
official docket in next term.
And regarding the bounty
hunter provisions,
the DOJ asserts that
enforcement by private citizens
makes them state actors.
But again, here, the fifth
circuit has already ruled on
that particular argument and
the Supreme Court dismissed
the argument on the shadow docket.
So it's extremely unlikely
that the DOJ is going to get
a second bite at the apple
on that particular issue,
especially when the fifth
circuit is already weighed in and
the Supreme Court has
approved of that decision.
And speaking of that court of appeals,
the fifth circuit finally
wrote an opinion to explain
this decision in whole women's health.
This is actually unrelated
to the new DOJ lawsuit,
but according to the fifth circuit,
SB8 emphatically precludes
enforcement by any state local
or agency officials,
the defendant officials thus
lack any enforcement connection
to SB8 and are not amenable to
suit under Exparte vs Young.
Therefore the fifth circuit
of Pines that the plaintiffs
don't have any claim against
the state licensing officials,
namely the executive directors
of the Texas medical board,
Texas nursing board, or the
Texas board of pharmacy,
or the state health and
human services commissioner.
The court says it's
mindful that SB8 violates
people's constitutional rights,
but that women can't sue
at this particular time
and that they might be
able to sue in the future.
Here's that language.
"We are mindful that SB8 applies
to pre-viability abortions,
which may raise serious
questions regarding
the constitutionality of the Texas law,
the citation, but also see,
noting the courts order
in no way limits other
procedurally proper
challenges to the Texas law,
including in Texas state courts."
So effectively the fifth circuit
is saying that the only way
to challenge this law is to
wait for a person to sue under
the bounty hunter provision,
and then raise the
constitutionality of SB8
as a defense to liability.
And the fifth circuit was
certainly not going to waste
the decision of the Supreme
court, stating quote,
"We are also mindful of
the real world effects
while courts resolve these
vexing procedural questions.
But we point out, as
did the Supreme court,
the potential SB8 defendants
will be able to raise defenses
before state courts that are bound
to enforce the constitution."
So unfortunately,
there's going to be a ton
of confusion while we wait
for someone to try to enforce
the bounty hunter provisions,
at which time the defendant
will then try to claim
that SB8 was unconstitutional
from the get-go.
In which case, we'll be right
back in front of the courts,
making all of these same arguments again.
So do you need to vent
about the court's decisions
or maybe call your Congress person,
get them to pass a legislative solution?
Well, if you don't throw your
cell phone out the window
in frustration,
you can actually save a
ton of money on that call
with Ting Mobile today's sponsor.
In fact, I personally
switched to Ting Mobile
and save literally hundreds
of dollars a month.
I'm not kidding.
Why?
Well, because of this, yes,
that is a real cell phone bill that I got
with my previous provider.
And that's why I
personally switched to Ting
and Ting Mobile has three brand new plans
to make sure that that never happens.
All of Ting's plans have
unlimited talk and text,
starting at just $10 per month.
So you can use the flex plan
and only pay for what you use,
which is especially great if
you're around wifi all day,
or choose a set of 12
gigabytes of data for $35,
or get full unlimited
for just $45 a month.
Switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep
your same phone number
and pretty much use any phone.
The service is great too,
because Ting partners
with several massive networks,
probably the very same one
that you're using right now,
but at a huge discount.
They literally use the
exact same infrastructure.
Now, actually, I can't
tell you which ones,
because I always respect contracts,
but let's just say that my
service hasn't changed at all,
except for getting much, much cheaper.
You can sign up for Ting's flex
plan that lets you just pay
for what you use.
Now, they just give you the possibility
of unlimited versions as well.
So if you want unlimited,
you can go absolutely crazy.
It's incredibly easy
to transfer a service,
just by simply ordering a ting SIM card,
popping it in and setting it up.
No phone calls required, it's like magic.
But if you do want to talk to Ting,
you can call them up
and immediately talk to
a real human being or talk to
a real human on chat or discord.
I used to be on the phone for
hours with my last provider,
but never with Ting.
Now, if you'd like to give Ting a try,
Legal Eagles will get a $25 service credit
that could cover two months of service.
All you have to do is
click on the link below
and give it a try.
You can click on the link that's onscreen
or in the description.
You'll get a free $25 service credit
and save a ton on your mobile phone bill.
So just click on the
link that's on screen.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're there,
check out this playlist with
all of my real law reviews,
covering the most important
legal issues of the day.
So click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.